en plateau je reçois à présent Caroline
baghiga bonsoir à vous bonsoir et
bienvenue directrice de l'ADIL 78
l'Agence départementale d'information
sur le logement dans le département des
Yvelines structure qui existe depuis
2007 c'est un guichet unique
d'information autour du logement de
l'habitacle comment accéder à la
propriété vos droits mais aussi vos
devoirs en tant que locataire et que
propriétaire l'ADIL qui existe depuis
2007 à quoi sert véritablement cette
structure quelles sont les
renseignements précis qu'on peut obtenir
quand on se rend auprès de vos services
c'est très simple quand on se rend
auprès de la deal on rencontre des
conseillers juristes qui ont une
formation de Bac + 5 endroits
immobiliers et qui vous apporte toutes
les réponses aux questions que vous
posez sur l'accès au logement par
exemple les problématiques de
copropriété des questions pour accéder à
la propriété comment acheter à quel taux
se faire élaborer des simulations de
financement c'est annuellement 11000
yvelinois qui viennent désormais nous
rencontrer tous les ans trois grandes
missions informations toutes formations
observation également justement
peut-être sur ce point on entend parler
de la du ralentissement de la hausse des
prix des difficultés aussi pour les
personnes qui ont des beaucoup plus
faible pour se loger quelle est la
situation dans les grandes lignes
aujourd'hui qu'on peut faire sur le
département la situation dans le
département elle est un peu celle qu'on
peut constater au niveau de l'Hexagone
c'est-à-dire que on a un ralentissement
de toute l'activité économique qui porte
sur le l'immobilier du fait de la
disparition de certains outils qui
permettaient par exemple à des prix moi
excédents c'est-à-dire à des ménages qui
n'ont jamais été propriétaires depuis
deux ans au prêt à taux zéro par exemple
nous on a directement été impacté dans
notre activité par la disparition du
dispositif pour pouvoir acheter dans de
l'ancien il faut savoir qu'aujourd'hui
c'est un dispositif qui a été recentré
dans le 9 mais au-delà de ça on est
confronté à un problème qui lui est
majeur c'est la difficulté effectivement
acheter avec des prix de sortie au mètre
carré qui sont très élevés dans le 9
qu'on donne dans le comme dans de
l'ancien puisque les Yvelines c'est
quand même effectivement un département
très attractif il faut le reconnaître là
on est sur la question pour devenir
propriétaire pour acquérir véritablement
en ce qui concerne peut-être plus le
logement le logement social le
gouvernement qui fixe objectif de 150
000 logements sociaux dès 13 on peut
imaginer des constructions à venir assez
nombreuses sur le département parce que
déjà est-ce qu'il y a des terres
indisponible est-ce qu'il y a des
finances aussi pour ça quels sont les
observations que vous pouvez faire sur
le terrain les observations qu'on peut
faire sur le terrain c'est qu'on a 39000
demandeurs de logement locatifs sociaux
qui sont en cours dans le département
des Yvelines ce qui est énorme ça fait
effectivement peu de place peu d'élus le
nombre de logements sociaux à l'échelle
du département et de 115 000 on a un
taux de rotation qui est extrêmement
faible puisqu'une fois effectivement un
ménage rentré dans le parc social
généralement puisqu'il ne peut pas en
sortir pour pouvoir acheter il y reste
donc on peut dire que la situation est
assez difficile elle est même très
compliquée le délai d'attente moyen dans
les Yvelines on le sait et de trois ans
et le nombre de demandeurs qui ont pu
être éligibles aux droits au logement
opposable s'élève à peu près à 2500 par
an et le nombre de relâchements et
effectivement pas très élevé donc la
situation peut sembler alarmante mais je
pense que tout est mis en oeuvre dans le
département pour pouvoir y remédier à
commencer par les politiques
départementale qui sont mis en oeuvre
pour encourager effectivement les
communes à pouvoir construire le
problème vous l'avez dit c'est le
foncier il faut ensuite trouver des
terrains disponibles il y a eu de
nombreuses polémiques ces derniers temps
ces dernières semaines autour des
logements décents des tout petits
logements quelques mètres carrés
forcément très insalubre même la
Fondation Abbé Pierre pardon qui a rendu
à un son rapport il y a quelques
semaines 3,6 millions de personnes sont
malgées en France là aussi même question
dans le département il y a des des sites
des appartements des logements qui sont
insalubres qui sont loués aussi oui on
constate elle a dit une augmentation de
plus de 20% des questions qui portent
sur la les logements indécents et les
logements insalubre mais on n'est pas
sur les mêmes problématiques que la
première couronne parisienne qui sont
effectivement sur des micro logements
qui sont loués ici on est sur un parc de
logements qui a été construit avant 1975
pour beaucoup qui sont effectivement
aujourd'hui des vrais passoires
énergétiques et qui mériteraient d'être
réhabiliter et cela aussi bien pour le
parc public pour le parc privé donc on a
effectivement quelques poches qui ont
été identifiées dans le département mais
qui sont traités les les élus locaux les
pouvoirs publics en place quelquefois ça
prend du temps notamment quand c'est
dans le cadre de certaines copropriétés
des laveries ou des qui sont et qui ont
été transformés en chambre par exemple
donc le problème est existant mais il
n'est pas prégnant non plus dans les
Yvelines et vous apportez des réponses
concrètes pour les spectateurs qui nous
regardent s'ils ont des problèmes de
logement
on les aidera à remplir une fiche de
signalement cette fiche fera l'objet
d'une remontée au service de l'État
notamment à l'Agence régionale de la
santé ou à la direction départementale
des territoires et un traitement sera
apporté à leurs questions juridique mais
aussi financiers et tout cela est
gratuit bien entendu
il y a un site internet aussi qui va
s'afficher à
1078.org vous êtes venus avec un certain
nombre de documents
sur le plateau on les aperçoit à l'image
ce sont des outils qui sortent à quoi ce
sont des outils pédagogiques il y en a
un qui s'appelle je me loge donc c'est
un jeu pédagogique qu'on vient de
d'acquérir et qu'on souhaite diffuser
auprès des des foyers de jeunes
travailleurs des Clash des missions
locales pour pour pouvoir permettre à un
jeune d'appréhender la question du du
rapport locatif de la façon la plus
ludique possible je le vois sur la boîte
c'est écrit de 0 de 2 à 77 ans jusqu'à
12 jusqu'à 12 personnes ensuite l'ADIL
est en train de
terminer puisqu'on a pas bien vu à
l'image c'est sous forme de plateau de
jeu hein
des questions avec des thématiques et
vous construisez une maison donc le
juriste de l'ADIL à Nîmes cette ce jeu
et ça permet d'appréhender des notions
qui sont pas si simple que ça et puis
c'est tellement plus simple d'apprendre
en jouant plutôt que d'avoir une
formation un peu un peu rigide c'est
disponible auprès de vos services c'est
disponible
alors le deuxième outil qu'on va publier
dans quelques jours c'est un guide on
vient d'en parler se loger dans les
Yvelines voilà un double qui est ce
décline effectivement en deux parties
une partie juridique une partie pratique
on a recensé en tout cas on a essayé
d'être totalement exhaustif la totalité
de l'offre de franchement disponible
territoire par territoire vous cherchez
un logement social un logement privé un
logement pour un senior un logement
adapté à votre handicap vous êtes jeune
on a essayé de recenser territoire par
territoire la totalité de l'offre
actuellement disponible dans les
départements
j'ai aperçu justement ces logements
étudiant on peut peut-être appeler que
c'est en ce moment qu'il faut remplir
les différents dossiers sur les
logements étudiants c'est certainement
jamais de le dire au moment de le dire
et je pense qu'il va sortir
effectivement au bon moment il y a des
difficultés encore aujourd'hui pour le
logement étudiant il y a plusieurs
constructions qui sont en cours à
Élancourt par exemple on en avait aussi
parlé et on en reparlera prochainement
il y a assez de construction aujourd'hui
en tout cas elles sont en cours et
vraiment le département des Yvelines
encourage vivement les collectivités à
le faire et apportent une aide qui est
sensible et c'est une problématique dans
les élus se sont appropriés le le sujet
ils essaient d'apporter une réponse
j'aimerais vous faire réagir juste pour
conclure sur les différents ministères
qui vont recevoir de Jean-Marc Ayrault
le Premier ministre leur directive
budgétaire la ministre de l'Égalité des
territoires et du logement à d'ores et
déjà indiqué qu'elle le thème moins de
rigueur des économies seront faites
c'est une certitude est-ce que vous
aussi vous pensez comme Cécile Duflot
qu'il faut des investissements je cite
juste et de longue durée en ce qui
concerne le logement il faut pas passer
à la trappe justement le logement il
faut continuer à investir oui il faut
non seulement investir mais il faut
investir sur un plan quinquennat le
problème aujourd'hui du logement c'est
que on a trop souvent de modifications
qui interviennent régulièrement tous les
ans les dispositifs n'ont pas le temps
d'être appropriés par les personnes donc
il faut effectivement qu'on puisse avoir
quelque chose sur une période un peu
plus longue et je pense que ça sera une
efficacité totale sur le département et
en France merci à vous d'être venu nous
éclairer sur ces questions du logement
vous êtes la directrice de l'ADIL l'ADIL
qui vous recevra si vous cherchez des
informations sur le logement comment
accéder à la propriété on le disait tout
à l'heure ou encore pouvoir faire valoir
vos différents droits il y a des
juristes essais gratuits qui peuvent
vous conseiller à suivre ce 18 février
le sport ce qu'il faut retenir des
derniers jours dans le département mais
déjà une nouvelle crèche
inter-entreprise qui vient d'ouvrir à
Montigny son nom mon tipi elle acc
ueille une trentaine d'enfants réservés
aux parents salariés d'entreprises du
quartier d'activité du pas du lac
reportage
mon tipi c'est la quatrième crèche
inter-entreprise de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines ouvert depuis
le 2 janvier la crèche du groupe people
and baby peut accueillir 31 enfants
âgé de trois mois à 4 ans les enfants
sont séparés en deux sections petit
moyen et moyen grand
Fanny la maman de Maceo 4 ans est
enthousiaste il est beaucoup plus
épanoui on sent qu'il a envie de venir
il fait des choses il a des activités
qui lui sont proposées et c'est ce qui
lui mangeait en fait chez la nourrice
déjà l'environnement ils arrivent c'est
pas une télé un canapé c'est des jeux
c'est un environnement adapté pour eux
des tables à leur hauteur et puis après
voilà il y a des activités ils font des
chapeaux pour mardi gras
voilà on leur propose du dessin de la
peinture c'est c'est vraiment adapté
pour eux
mon tipi à Montigny-le-Bretonneux est
uniquement accessible aux parents
salariés de la Banque Populaire Val de
France et du groupe Bouygues
Construction avec des horaires flexibles
8 heures 19 heures la crèche souhaite
offrir des services supérieurs au crèche
municipal
l'architecture de la crèche c'est très
bien pensé on a un matériel
pédagogique
on est énormément gâté et on a des
professionnels diplômés ce qui n'est pas
le cas dans toutes les structures dans
toutes les crèches vous n'êtes pas
obligé d'habiter la commune pour avoir
une place votre seul contrainte à vous
finalement c'est que soit le papa soit
la maman fasse partie de partie d'une
entreprise qui réserve des places et
vous êtes sûr d'avoir votre place de du
tout petit âge du bébé jusqu'à ce qu'ils
partent à l'école et ça c'est super
parce que bon bah voilà c'est c'est ça
ça rentrait serein et l'enfant et le
parent bien sûr
pour les parents le tarif et le même que
pour les crèches municipales il varie de
87 centimes d'euros à 2 euros 83 par
heure selon les revenus et le barème
fixé par la Caisse d'Allocations
Familiales couches soin et alimentation
bio tout est fourni l'entreprise
adhérente elle cotise à la hauteur du
nombre de places réservées